[Music]
in worst headache ever news worst hoodie
submitted by Ronan hi Ronan brandon's
dog yeah
a woman passes out after a splitting
headache wakes up thinking she's in 1980
oh that's a cool era to wake up in
though you didn't though oh she didn't
wake up in 1980 she woke up in 2019 how
old is she 56
oh she does she was in 1982 yeah did she
have that made her pass out like that
well so they're saying that she has been
diagnosed with transient global amnesia
the TGA transient gold well that sounds
like homeless worldwide a museum called
homeless yes she lost the last 38 years
of her life actually just like the
memories got the memory of the last
three don't like oh that's weird that's
great
so she got started all over again
yeah so her name is Kim she was leaving
Bible study at her local church when
then she called her husband she was
complaining about this excruciating
headache and that she had blurry vision
so he told her to go to the emergency
room but then some friends found her
passed out in the church parking lot and
then they rushed her to the hospital and
then the first thing that she remembers
waking up is a nurse asking her
questions asking her like do you know
what today is
and what year you're in she's like yeah
1980 she's like can you tell me who the
president is like yeah Ronald Reagan and
then the nurse / and then her husband
but she didn't know she the stranger
walked into the room Oh [ __ ] who the
hell are you grabbed her hand and she
said oh mine he had like tears in his
eyes and then she was like oh so this is
old guy it turned out to be her husband
David of 17 years what if her husband
was like oh she's an 8 1980 so he gets
in 1980 clothes and he shows up with a
[ __ ] like
daddy bag tie-dye shirt is [ __ ] or like
except he's 61 and she thinks it she's
20 she she was about to turn 18 in 1980
so she she's like the last thing she
remembers is being 17 about to turn 18
mad she goes up to marriage like she did
old [ __ ] yeah let me show you
guys I wonder if she still feels 17
she's like I'm part of s but oh yeah
show you a video clip that's the first
thing that you think you know I would I
feel younger gay do you know what year
it is and I said yes it's 1980 she knew
that Ronald Reagan was president but
everything after 1980 was erased she
didn't even know her husband David hope
they were married in 2000 and he looks
like Krusty the Klown him he had tears
in his eyes and I thought oh man Homer
Simpson the real-life version I'm your
husband Kim didn't even recognize
herself when I woke up I was about to
turn 18 and I looked in the mirror and I
was like this is not this is not 18 whoa
I wonder she was like what's all this
technology yeah that's what was that in
flat-screen TV Bannerman's relearning
everything she's still slowly trying to
come back yeah none of these memories
are gonna come back like they were they
don't think that she's ever gonna get
these Wow
I wonder from the concussion at all or
just from the headache I don't know
something like psycho mom you said
personality yes she gave birth to two
kids oh no she has two boys that she
raised that are her nephews and then she
has three stepchildren so that equals
seven kids that she does not remember at
all and she also has grandchildren dude
that would [ __ ] suck dude I missed
out so many parts of my life I know and
she also had to like real I go through
the grief again of her mom and her
brother oh my gosh the woman passed away
because in her head she was just 17 and
they were right there and then suddenly
you got wrinkles and
and you're like way heavier than you
used to be your [ __ ] don't work the
same 1350 I'd rather do the opposite I
rather fast forward but physically I'm
younger I know do things like before I
know in my head I'm like 90 but then I'm
like 10 kidding she was also like
emotionally stunted too like she like
you know the difference between like a
teenager and a fully grown adult yeah
emotionally like is what their
experiences yeah choose to Laberge her
husband what you don't know that
two-second crazy dude who knows uh-huh a
tease it was right after 70-79 know
there was no boundaries no boundary come
blasting everywhere mm-hmm and she might
have muscle memory by she might not have
mental memory but she might have Billy
[Laughter]
dude that was suck because you're 18
right and your image of an attractive
man
is not this do that you're married to
and then you have a son it was like a
new kids on the Montt guy that you were
in love with yeah
can you imagine you're 18 and all of a
sudden you're a bowl and you're married
to 50 more Simpson yeah so her husband
was saying like yeah it's kind of weird
because it's like I'm married like a
married 10 18 year old now so yeah we
were saying like the emotional
intelligence oh really it just resets
yeah it went back can we like party time
uh I know yeah cause what if she's like
this is boring I want to do some party
[ __ ] my back my back and hips [ __ ]
her bust a little bit oh my god yeah
like that movie young girl huh you know
how do you like wouldn't you at that one
movie were you like wake up and then you
see Friday it was like they switch
switch roles Freaky Friday yeah it's
pretty good Friday with the mom daughter
yeah yeah
ilan hands yeah yeah yeah Freaky Friday
well there's an original original one
yeah that's crazy that's like real life
but then there's nothing else she's
gonna be like super like just
hyper-emotional maybe cuz you know the
18 year old all 18 old kids were crazy
girls she was meant to die but she did
it and then someone yeah time traveled
and then during the I was they they they
entered her mind yeah that's too much
cuz you you write 18 is like when my
friend he was keys I think 25 or so he
got on tender I was trying to help you
know help my man set up I was how would
I pick our pictures you know you write
this you got to write a bio and when he
was doing his preferences I was like
nope 23 and up below that we are [ __ ]
crazy like their son y'all are easier
before that dude no 18 to 22 were y'all
[ __ ] crazy 18 to 22 what's your
definition of crazy girls are crazy
regardless I was correct like I was
insanely insecure I was like a little
just like at like I don't know I I
didn't have my priorities in order I was
doing things based off of what I wanted
in my emotions rather than what was best
for you know a couple and like other
things like just relative to who they
are both there's 40 year olds that still
are like that oh yeah it's really high
in guys remember half the stupid [ __ ] I
said when I was 18 I just want to go
back in time so I can beat the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of dude I would beat the [ __ ]
out of myself at 18 I'll be like you uh
remember I'll tell my girlfriend that
I'm like dude [ __ ] this school thing I'm
just gonna [ __ ] it be a standard come to
travel the war was not possible still
happen actually what you mean it wasn't
that dumb because I thought about it for
a minute I was like I moved out of my
parents house I was like wait a minute I
got a paper plate bills when I was like
17 18 you know and I'm going back in I
would I just needed like a slip you know
quickly slap
imagine being 18 and your future self
just comes dressed all normal look looks
good they just look at you slap you
across the face then leave 18 what they
would be free to look like me just hit
me
uh I feel like I would have okay who's
this [ __ ] skinnier guy dude it's like
I finally lost weight because dude it
happened bro [ __ ] it just way to hell
you want it here I just wait it out wait
it out instead of work hard and get it
earlier yeah yeah you could tell them
they start walking an hour a day that's
what I did dude all it takes duty is to
just walk really
hey no he's walking weed and I get
jumped in the neighborhood oh no oh yeah
that were you described about her like
she was supposed to die and then someone
went into her brain did you see that
show on Netflix that's why you said it
okay cuz they did a show like that where
they time-travel but they've jumped into
people's brains that are supposed to die
but right before they die they get this
crazy-ass headache and then they change
it to a different person it's like the
corniest show ever it but I like it I
like those people who have like brain
and brain [ __ ] that happens and they
wake up and they speak a different
language yeah yeah like that one Irish
lady that spoke Chinese
yeah like fluently like it was like
legit [ __ ] man I don't know how do
you explain that
we're like Flatliner I mean it's another
movie but Flatliners how they they die
for a few seconds or whatever and then
they come back and they had like this
crazy-ass talent like one could play the
piano
insanely great easy dude I would love
for that [ __ ] to happen yeah cuz I think
it might be a different soul that just
enters your body and replaces it there's
those who possess [ __ ] but in a good way
only be order you learn something and
even know you learned it you may be
awesome and play the piano and already
learned it your brains like I got that
[ __ ] but then but doesn't want to share
yeah but then now you like did something
to it now you learn it yeah I want to
learn how to unlock sir in the [ __ ] like
that cuz I watched this one child genius
show where they would play a song and in
by ear the kid could just recreate it
yeah like [ __ ] an axe we all have
that ability we just haven't unlocked it
yet that would be amazing
like all of us can secretly speak
Mandarin and we just have to unlock it
yeah do maybe if I just pretend to speak
you've it'll just happen when the
teacher I said say sorry so it's a story
said if you keep kids right like they
don't even learn they have to learn
language from scratch whereas like for
when you're an adult you can go oh it's
similar to this language which is
similar to this language and you have
other tools like
you already have a language to start
with harder that you can that you can
beat what's hard because you don't
remember how hard it was wait so so if
you already know English right you could
be like oh it's like this so it has the
same rules and you tie it together and
then you can learn that way but as a
child you don't even know how to
communicate with another human being
you're just absorbing so I think what
language is is its emotions thrown
through sounds and then that's why I
think sometimes women learn language way
faster than men do mm-hmm we just have a
lot of like mental barriers like women
are motion sounds somebody write that
down Instagram story where he was
imitating Korean you son of a [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was so funny
Whitledge it sounded like my style and
dude I was listening to it I was like
you know what I'm a little mad but I
should really do something creative like
if I was just walking by I'd have been
like that guy's fluid Oz freestylers is
straight there's just my flow so good
you watch my stories you should check it
out see that's your problem oh it's
always its tyka or it's something else
this one's stupid yeah hilarious is
something stupid or Teicher I've been
learning how to use stories
[Music]